partir à lviv à l'est d'al ouest de
l'ukraine c'est dans cette ville
notamment que l'ambassade de france
s'est replié c'est là aussi que de
nombreux ukrainiens trouvent refuge sur
place on retrouve cyril payen notre
envoyé spécial cyril bonsoir vous êtes à
l'entrée de la ville comment ça se passe
autour de vous
écoutez je ne sais pas si vous voulez
voir il fait déjà très très froid ici
dans cette ville d'un million
d'habitants est là comme tous ces
volontaires qui sont derrière nous
george s baic va vous montrer il ya d un
bunker qui est en train d'être construit
donc ce qui est absolument incroyable
c'est cette mobilisation populaire dans
cette ville qui est en fait qui
concentrent des centaines de milliers
d'ukrainiens de cet exode massif que
l'on voit depuis quelques depuis
quelques jours vers la pologne qui est à
70 km à l'ouest de là à l'aise de la
route à l'ouest pardon de là où on se
trouve et cette mobilisation populaire
vous avez derrière moi des hommes et des
femmes donc il faut ne pas pour tous
montrer les visages médias des
architectes des ingénieurs des étudiants
il ya même un joaillier qui est là qui a
une galerie qui est venu pourquoi et
bien pour remplir des sacs de terre et
construire tous ces bunkers donc c'est
un endroit sensible ils ont accepté que
nous fassions ce reportage en direct
avait avec eux au prêt après beaucoup de
des négociations mais ils sont là pour
toute la nuit ils viennent de mettre une
frise pour garder l'entrée de cette
ville donc en fait c'est toute une ville
qui se mobilisent pour se défendre c'est
le grand checkpoint le grand barrage
d'entrée à lviv parce que tout le monde
pense ici que la guerre va continuer à
se propager en ukraine va venir danser
pour ces endroits de l'ouest de
l'ukraine nous sommes à 500 kilomètres
de kiev mais ici aussi on se prépare à
la guerre vous pouvez le voir ces hommes
et ces femmes se sont mobilisés il fait
extrêmement froid mais tout le monde
tout le monde a abandonné son travail sa
famille pour venir se mobiliser ici pour
fabriquer ces endroits défensive pour
cette ville de lviv tous unanimement
nous ont dit préalablement qu'ils se
battront jusqu'au bout personne ne va
partir ils vont rester ici pour défendre
comme ils l'ont dit nord la patrie
chrétienne et abattre celui qu'ils
appellent le tyran poutine il ya un an
grand grand esprit de mobilisation de
communautés ici elles vivent merci
beaucoup cyril payen en direct de